you've seen love you've seen love break
down completely what role does Love play
in The Human Condition
I mean
I think it's kind of everything right
like it's love is romantic love like
Wars are fought for romantic love
Empires fall because of romantic love
like it takes down Kings it it takes
down you know like it's it's we're all
just struggling for it we're all just
chasing it like we're all chasing the
dragon you know it's like the rush we
all are so it's huge you know it's huge
I mean
sex
and love which I like to believe are in
some way connected
um and love and romance which again I
like to believe are in some way
connected
I think it's huge I think it's a
look I I've always thought
most of what men do including me we do
to get laid
like on some level
like you you want to be successful why
so you can have money why so you can
have nice things so that you can attract
attractive members of the opposite sex
you know like a lot of things come down
to that
and even for like men you know like red
pilled you know men who are like yeah I
don't care about women well you talk
about them all awful lot like for
someone that's not interested in women
you sure are like in the orbit of women
who you're telling how much you don't
care about women which kind of feels
like you're doing that to attract a
certain kind of woman which I get you
know like more power to you but like
that a person who worships an idol and a
person who destroys an idol are both
idolaters yes you know so you're you're
if all you're talking about is how you
don't need women you're talking about
women an awful lot so it's just such a
splinter in people's mind you know
relationships breakups
and and like it's such a great equalizer
I mean you're spending some time in the
rarified air now of like big celebrity
people and I remember when I started out
as a lawyer just doing like the regular
like the cop and the teacher with a 401k
and they didn't have any assets I
remember thinking like well someday if I
represent celebrities or wealthy CEOs
like they'll be different they'll be
like smarter they'll be like different
it's just
weird petty the same infidelity the
same the same kind of insecurities the
same kind of jealousy the same kind of
fights it all the same but it is it's
like it and it's all the same
insecurity sadness it's the same like
desire to be validated like mommy issues
daddy issues like intimacy issues you
know it and it's all the same stuff and
and just because you're really good
at other things like I've represented
professional athletes who are phenomenal
world-class you know doctors business
people and they suck at relationships no
better than like anybody else like
there's no
you know there's no connection between
the skills that made you a good
entrepreneur and the skills that made
you a good you know spouse or partner
I'm sure there's some overlap like
patience is good and thinking
strategically is probably good but I I
I'm
I'm just humbled by how we're called to
it still again so and and even when we
lose and even when like our greatest
pains were caused by our desire to love
and be loved in a romantic sense we just
keep putting the money on the table and
playing like we won't just quit we just
keep going you know and the whole mess
of it is worth it I I mean I guess I
guess so like there it's calling us I
don't know if it's worth it or not
that's a value judgment right but I I it
we don't stop
I don't know a lot of people that that
they played the hand they lost and they
went well no more of that game for me
like I'm not a good poker player I'm not
playing poker anymore like I know people
who've done that I know people that are
like listen I don't drink like you know
I'm allergic I break out in handcuffs
and hospital bills like I'm not drinking
anymore
but I don't know people that are like
man that relationship I screwed that up
or I got screwed on that one I'm not
doing that anymore you can say that
everybody says that I'm through with
love you know I'm done they're not they
keep going they'll they'll they'll go up
again